this is a production of Cornell
University
but i'm going to start this talk out
differently than ever before hmm so who
in this room likes landscape paintings
who doesn't like landscape paintings I
was somebody who didn't love landscape
paintings but I have turned around and
you'll see why I'm talking about this in
a minute but I mean my work is all about
biomass but the Hudson River School of
Art right was in the mid 1800s they were
American painters whatever that meant to
be an American in 1800 they were
landscape painters and they the school
was sort of along the hudson river but
they also went out west some famous
names are Thomas Cole Friedrich church
Albert Bierstadt assured erlend and
George NF so what do you think of this
one what's what's what's the feeling in
this image epic God grandeur amends huge
hunting wild what's the feeling in this
one foreboding heat ominous
yeah I should do this more often um how
about this one what's going on in this
one yep agriculture of course you're the
first to say that the first time
impending doom a dog there's also this
little umbrella that's forming and a
little top hat down here how about this
one what's going on on this one windy
there's a battle what are they wearing
those people in battle redcoats your
smoke has this one fuel
peaceful bucolic what not yet that comes
later how about this one how's this one
feel what
expansive prospecting maybe write some
civilization has this one feel settled
and how does that settling feel compared
to this one this is industrialization
right it's running on coal the trees are
cut off there's like it's not just
bucolic landscape it's like the
beginning of a city and then this one
right this is on the Hudson right the
industrial action of the fisheries so
the Hudson River School of Arts reflect
on three things of America in the 19th
century discovery exploration and
settlement and it covers these ranges of
experiences of you know you come here
and this diabolical fear of nature this
heavenly admiration of nature the
coexistence with nature the utility of
nature and the mastery of nature and
since my talk is about biomass I'm
fundamentally talking about the mastery
of nature but I want us all to remember
that all these other experiences of New
York I showed you in these images you
could think of them as just fantastical
paintings but they are actually
documents of other ways of being on the
same landscape right and we are making
real choices here as environmental
scientists about structuring the next
generation of what our landscape looks
like because certainly New York City
where I live doesn't look like any of
the images I have just showed you right
horizontal line it's like the first
thing I do for the first hour on the bus
when I'm coming here that's all I'm
looking for is the horizontal line and
that doesn't happen in New York and the
reason why it's happening right is we're
at such a huge population when i was
born in 1973 there were like half as
many people as there are now so we have
the same land mass but we have twice as
many people as when i was
and those paintings I just showed you
where when we had you know between one
and two billion people and that's the
whole earth when you came to the new
world when you came to America back then
there were some real ethical questions
about what to do I mean it was so
beautiful but then there were all these
resources that you could utilize and so
there was a battle between becoming
wealthy whatever that means and keeping
it pristine okay so here's a house of
you know your formal part of the talk
but I wanted to frame it that way so how
do we manage our landscape for food feed
fiber and fuel and this goes back to my
early work with John duxbury and what I
am continuing to do work with Peter and
specifically I'm going to focus on the
fuel component so a couple years ago
with here and many other people we did a
analysis of the New York State biomass
feedstock production sustainable
feedstock protection and it was based on
land availability land suitability and
biomass yield and you know we applied
all these different constraints I'm not
going to go over them I'm sure you know
force will stay as forests protected
lands meaning state and federal are not
used right existing wood products were
maintained dead and thirty-five percent
of tops were left in the forest for
biodiversity right we didn't consider
equine use not all landowners are going
to want to grow biomass right so only
fifty percent adopt roughly you know
herbaceous will remain herbaceous you
know we had all these factors that we
put into this in order to get this
biomass feedstock number that could be
sustainably produced in New York State
so here's that graph in some it's 14.2
ter grams of
mass for bioenergy per year this is our
existing production it's roughly the
same amount and this is what we think we
could sustainably produce in 2020 okay
so this is you know if this is what
we're producing in the state already and
we're doubling it it seems like a kind
of a large and ever it's going to change
certain things and practices but to give
you some context of what 14.2 tera grams
of biomass is this is the new york state
energy flow chart firm nyserda's 2015
publication but it's based on 2013 New
York State consumes 3665 tera BTUs so
funny i used the t all the time and then
you have these conversions and losses
which is basically only considering the
electricity so that our net consumption
is 2655 all right you know this is
petroleum is purple natural gas coal
other fuels which has nuclear hydro wind
these are sort of proportional shapes so
you can get a sense of what's going in
so this 14.2 tera grams if we just
convert it to a BTU value right just as
raw biomass accounts for seven percent
of this number okay so all of our
sustainable biomass seven percent of our
current energy consumption
so what we did was instead of looking at
returns on investments we looked at how
much how we could look at the processes
that this biomass would go through to do
the most work for society right you can
make gallons of ethanol you could make
kilowatt hours right those are products
in themselves but what we want to do
since we've got this finite land base
with this finite biomass on it we want
to do the most work for society so we
this whole analysis is about
fundamentally focused on the work so
it's a simple sort of input-output
analysis we use the basic unit of the
jewel it is a measure of comparing the
quantity of energy and it misses
something of the quality of energy right
not all energies are the same when you
compare them on a dual basis right they
might have the same jewels but you can
do a lot more with electric jewels than
you can do with heat Jules right so just
keep that in mind and then we look for
two types of works the two types of work
heating for homes or buildings and
transport as measured by distance
travelled in a vehicle so what are the
steps in the boundaries well we have to
plant and grow and harvest the biomass
then we have to move the wet biomass to
processing plant then we have to convert
the biomass to a usable form and then we
move that energy product to consumer so
there are many energy products right
that we could get out of the cellulosic
biomass it could be ethanol pellets
grain electricity but then we do one
more step which is we convert that
energy to work to think about the
end-use efficiency so for growing and
harvesting just to give you an idea I
mean this list is really long I'm not
going to go through the whole list with
you I'm just showing you three
attributes of comparing you know what
mais vs. willow you know you have to
plow mais every year you you plow for
the grass one every ten years and that
affects the energy for the plough and
the embodied energy in the plow so those
are some of the attributes that go into
looking at the energy at growing and
harvesting the biomass across the
different types of biomass then we have
to look at the moisture content of the
biomass because that affects the weight
when you're transporting it to the
processing center we look at the BTU
content or the giga joule content of
that biomass just you know calculate our
raw energy resource these are the
harvest costs that I just sort of
alluded to in the last slide and then
distance is that the biomass is
transported okay to a site so you know
you can see that maize grain was based
on our to ethanol plants so we only have
two ethanol plants in the state so
there's a farther distance that the corn
has to travel whereas in the other
scenarios we have 24 smaller biomass
plants around the state so they have a
shorter distance to travel right but I'm
just giving you some of them and this
calculates this translates into how much
of the dry biomass is spent towards
transportation energy right I'm just
there are many attributes but I'm just
trying to give you a sense of what's
going on then you get to the processing
plant we there are two existing maize
grain ethanol plants but you could also
use that same maize grain for pellet
stove there's one existing combined heat
and power plant that uses what wood
chips in lines Dale New York so you lost
it gettin all this was in collaboration
with our group for the analysis for
nyserda which is the next generation
cellulosic ethanol production and but
then you could also use that same
cellulose and make pellets which could
go into a pellet stove or you could make
those pellets go into a combined heat
and power plants to generate electricity
so these are some of the sin
areas that we saw for this biomass or
processing scenarios what you need to
know about these scenarios or these
processes is that they have different
numbers of steps right and the more
steps you do in a process generally you
lose energy so may his brain is
interesting right because that it's
fifteen point five percent moisture
content you could just pop it in the
store you don't have to do anything
before you get heat but all you're
getting out of that product is heat
right you're not getting electricity so
it depends on what you want some others
were one step so biomass was pelletized
for pellet stove the wet wood chips were
combusted in a real plant to generate
electricity and that plant was
twenty-two percent efficient and
generally electricity the maize grain is
converted to ethanol or the cellulose
biomass was converted to ethanol again
one step and you have a product that
people can use and then we wouldn't want
to step further and we did two steps
where you take that pelleted cellulose
and you generated electricity at thirty
percent efficiency or you put the
ethanol in to generate electricity at a
slightly higher conversion efficiency
oops so once you have your product
whether it's megawatts it has to go
through the grid and it loses fifteen
percent of its energy through the grid
or you use a truck to take it to the
distribution center ie gas station
whatever that was calculated and then
you have to look at the end-use
efficiency and this is kind of where the
crux of our analysis comes down I hope
you'll see it later but you know we put
maze in a 75 percent efficient pellet
stove the cellulose pellets we put in an
eighty percent efficient stove the
ethanol and eighty percent efficient
home boiler electricity is ninety-nine
percent efficient in generating heat in
a home for distance we
ethanol and the twenty percent efficient
internal combustion engine and we did
distance by you know electricity and a
75 percent efficient electric car okay
in addition there are potential
co-products and I say potential because
there's always products whether or not
they're used and considered products is
another matter right we call it wastes
generally because we have very poor
imaginations we use waste very
frequently so it made ethanol make dried
distillers grain that has a high value
for feed animal feed but remember this
analysis keeps everything on the jewel
level we're comparing everything with
jewels so even though this might have
more value in terms of producing beef or
milk or whatever this is just kept in
terms of jewels as pellets that could go
into a pellet stove okay so you lost the
kathan all has a small amount of
electricity that's generated as a
co-product and when you generate
electricity in a power plant you
generate tons of heat and you could
potentially capture that waste heat so
the Lions Dale biomass plant which runs
on wet wood chips up in Lyons fall in
New York and it's only twenty two
percent efficient at use to sell its
waste heat to a neighboring paper plant
and it would dry the paper at the paper
plant something happened and they no
longer do that and the paper plant now
has a natural gas heater to dry their
paper so even though these two companies
are close proximity again when energy is
cheap you don't have to cooperate right
you don't and that's a very real reality
the maize grain has no cool product
right you're just combusting it straight
for heat and same thing with the
pelletized cellulose for heat
um so the summary table that's coming up
is based on these five characteristics
so I'm going to try to go through this I
mean just this is important is what I
guess I'm trying to say so we start out
with this biomass right it's it's got a
volume it's got a character it's it's
got so many BTUs in it has a certain
moisture content whatever and when we
want to convert it we're going to go
through some processing losses okay it's
just that's what's going to happen it's
going to lose things in the process we
also had to put things in right we had
to use energy to apply nutrients to the
field we had we had to transport it by
car right so those are external inputs
okay then we want to do work with that
biomass right we want to heat our homes
and we want to travel distances that's
the end goal that's the product but when
we do that we lose energy right you lose
it's not an efficient system turning you
know ethanol into miles driven it's an
inefficient system so there are these
end-use losses and then there are these
co products that I just listed that
could be used but if we don't use them
than their waists right so these five
attributes that I'm talking about oops I
guess it's coming up not next I'll come
back to it I want to just talk about the
scale at which we're doing this these
analyses because you know scale matters
so one scenario is just green wood chips
an existing power plant of 20 megawatt
and it has a simple conversion
efficiency of twenty-two percent maize
grain to existing power plants right
it's fifty four percent efficient and
when I say simple conversion I mean
you're getting you're getting all this
ethanol
out without thinking about any of the
inputs that went into it ok so it's
fifty four percent of the biomass be to
you but not of the total energy system
beats you right it just means you put in
this much corn you got this much ethanol
out but you also put lots of other
things in so I'm just giving you these
simple conversion efficiencies to show
you the range at the very first step
without considering any of the other
things so of course maize grain and a
pellet stove right you're not talking
about the energy that went into making
the maize grain it's a hundred percent
efficient because you've got the corn
grain already in the form that you want
or you need to use in your pellet stove
and this is just sort of a summarizing
chart also of inputs and products so
there's the biomass energy content this
is the energy within the biomass that we
harvested and this is the Supplemental
energy that we had to add to it in order
to be able to make the products okay and
then we get these primary products which
is you know electricity ethanol grain
pellets electricity ethanol and
electricity and then these co products
that I was just talking to you about
before oops so here's the chart and I'm
going to do it in three doesn't have
labels because that comes the next one
I'm just trying to orient you to this
graph so each one of these bars is is a
mega gram or a unit of biomass when it's
above zero it's work that is
accomplished by sus by society for
society like distance traveled or homes
heated when it's below zero it means
that it's been lost somewhere in the
process right either was lost as an
input it was lost in the processing it
was lost in the end-use efficiency
alright and to orient you again these
are all about transportation and these
are all primarily about your primary
product being heat okay so next slide
adds more
so this is the processing loss while
you're converting the maize grain into
ethanol this is the process loss this is
how much product you make okay whenever
it's all this green whether it's striped
or not that's the amount of product to
make so when you're making ethanol I
don't know like fifty percent right I
said fifty-four percent for maize grain
so this is fifty-four percent of the
biomass it's turned into ethanol however
you had to use this much energy input so
I'm sort of deducting that even though
you could sell that ethanol you actually
need it to make the next generation of
ethanol this is when you take that
ethanol and you put it in your car and
you go miles but it's only in a twenty
percent efficient internal combustion
engine so that means only five percent
of the corn grain is going to traveling
distance and miles the rest of it is
going off as waste heat into the
atmosphere or maybe heating your car in
the winter right now this is the co
product if we don't use this co-product
it should come down here in most of
these scenarios we don't actually use
the co product but this is the potential
in this case it's dried distillers grain
and it is actually used for animal feed
okay so the point here is that these
numbers right here that's the proportion
of the biomass that's actually doing
work for society so if you and then this
up here is the co product that could do
work for society if we're clever about
it if we're not already using it okay so
clearly using the maize grain
or the pellet pelletized cellulose is
going to do the most direct work from
the primary product okay 64 or
sixty-nine percent of that biomass is
going to heat homes you know using it
five percent of it doing transportation
if it's ethanol corn ethanol all right
if we palletize this cellulose and we
put it in a combined heat and power
plant and regenerated electricity
nineteen percent of it could go towards
driving now if we would just use the way
to eat right the whole collective would
be sixty percent utility for society now
we have two products we've got heat
products and transportation products all
right we like this potentially if we
would use right because electricity is
very versatile it's a really powerful
fuel type right if we could just be
effective at using the waste heat then
this would be a great percentage that's
like sixty-two percent of the biomass is
going to products for society but it
requires some coordination so that that
waste heat is actually used so even
though this is like the bigger number
it's a bigger number for heat products
right so the value of the quality of the
energy is very different alright this
move down but this is supposed to be
highlighting this line but basically the
same biomass can use five to nineteen
percent of its photosynthetic energy to
drive miles vs the same biomass can use
12 to sixty-nine percent of its
photosynthetic energy to heat homes
right if the objective is to do work for
society how do we want to move what
kinds of things do we want to support
and we forward so to bring this home in
a 25 mile per gallon car I think the
average was 20
three recently I don't know I meant to
check on that but at an average of three
dot twenty-three census is averaged
across the last three years okay now I
recognize when I took my bus it was a
dollar fifty seven in New Jersey so you
can divide this by two and get your
number but I don't think a dollar fifty
seven is forever but anyways gasps at
323 a gallon electricity at eighteen
cents per kilowatt-hour ethanol at three
dollars a gallon and e 85 @ 294 gallon
would cost twelve dollars and
seventy-eight cents to use gas to go 100
miles vs six dollars and seven cents to
grow hundred miles an electric vehicle
okay now I just reduce this by half a
dollar fifty seven so right now they're
equal in terms of the cost right but I
you're getting it right look at it at a
different perspective so if we took all
the cellulose all the sustainable
cellulose from York State and we convert
it into ethanol and we made this many
gallons of ethanol at three dollars a
gallon it would cost the consumer 4.2
billion dollars to buy those gallons
right if we pellet all the cellulose for
electric cars and we converted it to
electricity at eighteen cents per
kilowatt hour it's 3.7 billion dollars
the consumer kind of the same price but
you can only drive 35 times 10 to the 9
miles vs 60 times ten to nine miles on
the same price right so everybody kind
of getting this
so these are my modest conclusions our
biomass only accounts for seven percent
of primary energy consumption we could
increase efficiency and all kinds of
levels but in this particular case I
hope it makes it clear the electric
vehicle versus the internal-combustion
vehicle and then thinking about
diversity of end-use right we're moving
away from just fuels for transportation
and thinking more cohesively about the
whole system and what we want to deliver
to society meanwhile we have to think
about seasonal changes and be sensitive
to climate changes and how this
intensifies the land base and what are
the competing uses for this land base
right we could all go back to the
bucolic images of the Hudson River
School that would be a choice or we
could get really inefficient cars and
have that right i mean we have many
choices there are there's tons of
competing land uses and generally less
conversion means greater social benefit
but it's remember it depends immediately
and more salable product does not mean
more societal work right that's kind of
the point and this last one I apologize
I just couldn't help myself but I'll
just move on so that is that I would
love to entertain questions thank
New York
I at this point I really like Colin is
endless right because even though it
doesn't in the maximum out of the
introduced in the house it give this to
hot and I think I mean to your important
I mean it's a serious is definitely
right as important as right but
electricity is incredible it has so much
pasta so while the easy answer is to say
you know pellet stoves or propelled by
Silas I I live in New York City I grew
up with a wood stove I have no interest
hit the lovely thing but a lot of people
are getting said that but this
electricity varies so we just have to be
[ __ ] we've got all kinds and just
really could use that way to it right or
we could just have smaller providing
power systems all over the place i'm
looking at aberdeen university and i met
the nice work
to figure out how you identify locations
that have combined for your harp systems
so that your electricity is go
generating week it's very simple and in
fact new city based on my Newton power
back in the day but we use pool which
made so much particulate matter and it
was actually hard but we have other
resources and what does it mean when you
generate your listening and usually you
just reduced you so much right you know
how to use another energy source to me
so I I am very much of my mindset my
meetin power not just providing mass
products but for all right and are you
guys married I don't know why yeah
with rose
it raises questions for me
meaning extracting nutrients from the
fields where the poor charlie okay so in
our offices that we did at the very
beginning of this presentation and
purpose or into a pest management or
what that means though as the urine like
what happens to the nutrients in the
power plant ash or get the most oh gosh
that is not so it's not fully cycling
it's just
I
it is useful
okay see you talking that when it says
26
so all of this all of these core
products appear with easily
this is a hug so the green is what
actually isn't products that we're using
this we're producing like the cellulosic
ethanol it makes electricity that wisdom
is being used that's not requiring
needs some
we
the coupons
lazy
in these two scenarios so the Winship
plant it used to use the waste heat to
dry paper paper paper plant and
equipment and in this scenario so this
is based off of a combined power pellet
plant that is done
but they don't use the least
but it just recite and it could be
what's the difference between the
primary and secondary product is because
it says he got tough oh ok so the
transportation
is between art
and the musical products
children are abused in this case
just by the one he picked out this is
going to what the actual
ok
what's the product was the primary club
so in this scenario okay okay in this
scenario and take peloton cellulose we
challenged electricity we move it to the
grid it comes to home and a goober
that's doing
ah
all right and I'm just trying to point
out right this is right here the same
thing
this column and this column are the same
electricity process and product but
different and risks okay
I
here enjoy my mystic seer
ok it's cool
you I mean it simple if you should
probably also reduce even the height of
the gray bars according to the
efficiency of whatever system would be
used for the waste products because that
I think that's a little bit misleading
because if you even if the efficiency
for for heat for some heat is only
twenty six percent I mean maybe the
efficiency for the waste products only
twenty-six percent that doesn't look as
attractive understood as you're safe in
okay so that i don't know pink is that
for suggestion improving this crowd
actually I love this graph here's Mary
to the pub and I did in a light gray
sort of match this gray because for all
intents and purposes you know this
should be a defect ok it's most of the
case
those are is not the range
that's why
it might be possible to add another x
ray the cases was for like an identified
mrs. principal
this is actually sort of this is being
done
we're Sumerians of some small real
function
what is the major limitation s why that
secondary
why why are you bonkers
so what's what a power plant not
I
the paper
all the most raw
go back to do some sort of that natural
gas connections our system negotiation
see me succeed but everything
it becomes a degree they're not going to
be putting in gas versus driver
with all these
we were
and we get out because
here's a reason why it's not
right that's the reason why it's all
being made
these are the problems while so anyway
right the one that one out we had sandy
and the whole lower half men have no
electricity right well that for teens we
always excuse me already have a
Chinatown all the ways teach the steam
keeps all those buildings great
it runs on natural gas
and
you know it also happens
which is why
if you just made the case of why is
being I would like to examine why I what
a little fishes so that was the context
of the Scorpion University in New York
City we had all commanders they were
pulled and making too much smoke in the
city with Megan
that is a busy week
Oh
we could
no one else providing tomorrow
me there's all kinds of locations first
there's an ex-military building a new
york city which is
because it was built in the 40s and his
3000
yes
but you can also think that it's a good
strategy instance
we've got too much apartments they're
smaller
place they're getting much better
overall efficiency it collected Ibrahim
as possible probably the most
so if you're easy with the waste heat to
complete like fifty percent of the
Bioman or the energy product that goes
in is way Steve we've just reduced to
your energy buddy
because you no longer be duplicating the
heat loss from the electric plant and
the heats you stay put so are you saying
that yes it's also economies
partners
whatever you going
I mean I think
operation
those texts
so cool
but that claims that
position
sushi
is that this
crash
we want to just
really fast
I will tell you years this year i was
born in my heart
but it was myself until that moment I
have never conceived
the governor on news my birthday is
and so for the first time my entire life
didn't have any huge
the white here is living in a
conceptually different moment like it
was passed
it is no longer inconceivable because
the system is rapidly changing so if we
want to be trusted imma change I would
argue that licking
electricity
and i don't mean that's what it has to
be for my press right clearly i hope you
recognize that all of this bomb ass
right you could have bucolic landscapes
instead of seven percent of our energy
just you can you give me energy to have
your colleague at six right I I can you
know these are the choices that you can
actually make and we're not making this
system because choices have you put a
price work on some ethical issues of
burning quarters
with burning walk out there today if I
had to choose if i have enough calories
on my body right now to make us through
the next two days that i had to be out
there with i would really like to so
like I don't have that issue
is that harness of energy
to produce that you can produce all
other
I don't think there's a few argument
right there's like you get up for or you
can look for ever
if you have any see God and you can
taste it
we're talking maybe i'll subtract
attending I mean sort of a literal sense
of the calculation this right potential
violence that's in addition to the food
and fibre roof every single state over
so did you go
so well yeah so it's going on land is
not currently producing developers now
that doesn't mean the poor thing
Oh
oh poor curls Parker little ways
rossa corn palace
emotions
excuse on you
using sort of extended up so you're
losing nutrients to produce fuel you
don't
could we change that we want to see
I
disagree
I got frustrated
there is hope
but an important part is
we should stop in here this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu